one of the biggest surprises to come out
of the hogwarts legacy state of play
event just a few short months ago
actually happened just after the event
and that was the confirmation from
avalanche that hogwarts legacy is coming
to the nintendo switch now i won't
personally be playing the switch version
but i was super pumped about this i know
there's a lot of folks out there who
don't have a next-gen console or they
just prefer the switch the on-the-go
nature of it i get it now here's the
interesting piece of this not a lot of
fanfare was made about this avalanche
did not talk about it at the state of
play event at all which i guess kind of
makes sense considering it's a sony
event but even after very little mention
it actually popped up on an amazon
listing where you could pre-order the
game and then it would later appear on
the official website where we still have
the logo today stating that it is in
fact coming to hogwarts legacy as well
as in the faq section of the website as
well now here's where things get
interesting because even though hogwarts
legacy is being developed as a crosston
title spanning ps4 xbox one generation
along with the current gen ps5 and xbox
series x generation many myself included
were pretty surprised to see hogwarts
actually coming to the switch primarily
due to the console's outdated hardware
now it certainly makes sense from a
business perspective right i mean you
just take a look at the insane sales of
the switch that is a huge install base
right there and hogwarts legacy is
really going to make sure that it is
across every console imaginable no
matter which console you have there will
be a way to play this game but there's
one little thing one little issue here
that keeps popping up here on youtube
related to the switch version and it's
people who keep saying that hogwarts
legacy on switch will likely be a cloud
version of the game now yes i'm familiar
with cloud technology but honestly i had
no idea this was a thing on switch i
just kept seeing it over and over and so
i'm like okay what the heck is going on
here is this actually a thing that's
been happening on switch turns out it
totally is this nintendo life article
here from back in march has a list of
games that are currently available only
through the cloud on the nintendo switch
and you can see it's certainly not a
huge list but there are some big name
titles on here head on over to the
official nintendo site and you'll find a
lengthy explanation there about cloud
gaming on the switch but here's the
short version of it a cloud version of a
game uses streaming technology to play
the game from a server the cloud version
requires a stable connection to
high-speed internet to play because the
game is streamed from a server the full
software is not downloaded to your
nintendo switch system a small download
is required to launch the game okay so
if you're familiar with streaming
technology or if you've experimented
with it at all then you know it is very
hit and miss obviously it's incredibly
reliable incredibly dependent on your
internet connection but regardless even
with a great internet connection any
streaming that i have ever tried i have
always found the latency the input delay
from the controller to the cloud back to
my game is always just too long for me
to handle now it's certainly gotten
better over the years but for me
personally can't do it i have to have it
downloaded directly to my system not to
mention this causes a huge issue with
one of the main selling points of a
switch version and that's the idea of
the portability you would not be able to
play the cloud version let's say you're
on a plane ride without wi-fi or you're
riding in a car with no wi-fi or even if
you're just traveling from place to
place where you don't have a consistent
reliable internet connection then you
would not be able to play hogwarts
legacy if it ends up being a cloud
version of the game now on the positive
side of all this nintendo does give free
trials for all cloud titles which means
you can try before you actually fully
commit to purchasing the game when it
comes to hogwarts legacy though
considering how little they've said
about the switch version it does leave
me to wonder if this could be yet
another title that will be added to this
growing list of cloud only games for the
switch i mean if you go to amazon or
best buy or gamestop right now online
you can pre-order the switch version of
hogwarts legacy and there is no
reference to it being a cloud only title
who knows maybe that's a good sign maybe
the fact that it doesn't have that on
the listing they're already like hey
this is confirmed why why would it not
be a full version of the game now one
other thing that i double checked for a
lot of these titles that they have cloud
versions for is i looked on amazon to
see if they have a listing for any of
them with an actual picture of a game
box that you can order because if you
think about this if there's a cloud
version you'd essentially be ordering a
box that would have nothing but a code
in it now i have seen this done before
but when it comes to these switch cloud
versions at least in the titles i looked
for i could not find it so perhaps this
is a sign that we do already have
confirmation that the switch is going to
be a full-fledged version but if that's
the case i still can't figure out why
they just wouldn't outright say it and
frankly while we haven't heard more
about it but then the other side of this
that we also have to consider is the
fact that playstation certainly has some
sort of marketing exclusivity deal with
hogwarts legacy playstation is certainly
going to want to make it seem like their
version of the game is the absolute best
place to play and honestly that would
probably also explain why the switch
version has really been downplayed since
the announcement and you know what let's
explore that a little bit why do people
think it cannot be a full version well
it mainly goes back to what we were
talking about with the outdatedness of
the switch hardware then you throw in
the fact that hogwarts legacy is a fully
open world game it would certainly be a
challenge to run on the nintendo switch
now that being said titles like the
witcher i can't believe that this
actually happened but if you guys didn't
know this the witcher 3 actually was
ported to the nintendo switch and i
haven't played it myself but i've heard
it's actually not bad of course it's not
going to be what it was on pc or even on
the consoles but it was not bad all
things considered now the witcher is a
much older title than hogwarts legacy
even though it was very advanced
graphically for its time now not so much
so i totally get why this rumor has kind
of started i totally get why people are
asking this question i just hope we get
an answer from my avalanche fairly soon
on whether or not the switch version is
a cloud version or whether it is a
full-fledged port now i want to be
totally clear here this is a rumor there
is no confirmation of this whatsoever i
have reached out to community manager
chandler wood here on twitter and given
the reaction to this tweet how many of
you like this tweet even though it was
sent directly to him i think there's
clearly a group of people who want to
know information about this so hopefully
this video will be outdated very quickly
and we'll have a firm announcement on
this we'll have a firm answer to go by
and personally i really hope it comes
from avalanche sooner rather than later
because i know folks i know some of you
out there are currently trying to decide
which version of the game you want to
purchase now even if it is confirmed
that it is a full-fledged port then we
have to say okay well actually how does
it run how well does this game run we
did get confirmation that at least the
ps5 version will include both a fidelity
mode and a performance mode which is
certainly a good sign but if you are
someone out there who is looking at the
switch version of the game maybe you're
even thinking about pre-ordering the
switch version of the game personally i
would wait wait until we get official
confirmation from avalanche on how this
version of the game performs and whether
or not it is a full port or a cloud
version you know i don't always love
doing rumor videos but this is one of
those that i think is very important to
you the audience out there it's
important for you to know this
information when you're thinking about a
buying decision and whether or not the
switch version is something you want to
pick up i even know some people who have
been thinking about the switch is kind
of a second version so they'll have a
game to play while they're on the go as
well but this would certainly pose a
potential issue for
that and here lately the hogwarts legacy
news has just been rolling in week after
week if you didn't catch all the news
from the latest playstation blog post
and short video then check out the video
on the right side of your screen right
now as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon